one of the things he's hanging Yerba
markets right now is clearly the vote in
the United Kingdom next week how much of
a factor was that in today's decision
relative to the questions you've
elucidated about the domestic jobs
numbers and inflation data and could you
talk a little bit about the channels
that you think about when you talk about
the potential impact of a brexit on the
US economy thank you well brexit the
upcoming UK decision on whether or not
to leave the European Union is something
we discussed and I think it's fair to
say that it was one of the factors that
factored into today's decisions clearly
this is a very important decision for
the United Kingdom and for Europe it is
a decision that could have consequences
for economic and financial conditions in
global financial markets if it does so
it could have consequences in turn for
the US economic outlook that would be a
factor in deciding on the appropriate
path of policy so it is certainly one of
the uncertainties that we discussed in
that factored into today's decision